there's so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves I've never tried a p
Louise product before but I kept seeing
this blush everywhere it's the cheek of
it liquid blush the formula is actually
water-based so it did blend into my skin
really easily I think maybe because it's
water-based it wasn't as pigmented as I
expected it to be I did add quite a bit
more to build up the color but I think
it turned out pretty and it didn't move
any of the product I already had on even
though I liked the end result I think
I've tried better liquid blushes this
lipstick keeps selling out everywhere
but I finally got my hands on a couple
Shades this is the Revlon super lustrous
glass shine lipstick it's one of those
lipsticks that kind of mimics a gloss so
you get this really pretty sheer wash of
color and that high shine finish these
are beautiful and feel so good on the
lips so I totally get the hype they
actually remind me of The Hourglass
glossy bombs except these are like 20
dollars cheaper miss a is that website
where all of the makeup is super
affordable I saw people raving about
their AOA plush blush so I had to try it
the packaging is literally like a nail
polish so it just felt a little odd
applying but I was really impressed with
this it's a gel formula so it's more
like a cheek stain that feels
lightweight these blend out so easily
and they are very pigmented I really
really love these I also picked up the
new AOA flaw eraser Foundation sticks I
got a few Shades so I could bronze and
highlight with these as well I got
nervous about how these were going to
look on my skin when I was applying
because they felt thick but once I
started blending it out with my brush
and I picked up the extra product with
my sponge it was so much better I wasn't
expecting these to be so full coverage
it is more of a matte formula but I
don't think it made my skin look dry and
all of my other products went on top of
this just fine I can't believe both of
these products are under two dollars
Charlotte Tilbury just released this
Hollywood glow Glide face architect
highlighter I got the shade Pillow Talk
glow it's supposed to give this sort of
soft focus glow rather than be super
glittery it also has emollients in it to
hydrate the skin which I don't think
I've ever tried a hydrating powder
highlighter I'm torn on this product
because from afar I think it looks
really beautiful but up close I feel
like it made my skin look a bit textured
to be fair my skin hasn't been great
lately it's been really dry and I've
been getting little breakouts so
highlighter is probably the last thing I
need right now I do think this is really
pretty I just don't think it works great
if you already have texture I don't
think I've purchased a Covergirl product
since high school but these glosses were
calling my name this is the new yummy
gloss these smell incredible the pinky
clear one smells like a pina colada and
the more burgundy one smells like
berries the scents really took me back
to like Old School lip smackers they
have this huge doe foot applicator which
I'm a fan of and they feel so good on
the lips super shiny and not sticky at
all I do have to mention that the
product description doesn't say this is
a Plumping gloss but I got this tingly
feeling on my lips when I applied it I
don't know if it's because it is plumpy
and they just weren't super clear about
that or if I'm allergic to something in
it but either way just had to let you
know made by Mitchell released powder
versions of its liquid blisters and
bronzers I'm not saying blush weird
that's just what they're called I do
have to say I'm not a fan of the
packaging just because it's not an easy
shape to store but onto the actual
products inside the packaging the
pigment on these is unreal I tapped my
brush off a lot and I still got full
color payoff this powder formula is
still easy to blend though it was easy
to diffuse the color without it getting
patchy or ruining my Foundation they
just look really smooth on the skin I
love these elf recently released a line
of color correctors I picked up the
peach shade to brighten up my under eyes
this formula is really creamy and easy
to work with I was worried it was almost
too Peach when I was applying it but my
concealer Blended on top of this really
nicely it actually did add some
brightness and you cannot beat that four
dollar price point makeup by Mario has
finally released its long-awaited
surreal skin Foundation station looking
at it in the bottle it looked glittery I
think because there's Mica in it the
formula itself feels slightly thick but
it did feel weightless once I applied it
to my face this covers a lot like I
couldn't see any of my discoloration or
acne through this I do think that this
Foundation did enhance my texture though
I mentioned in my last video that my
skin hasn't been great lately but I
still do good skin prep before
foundation this just kind of highlighted
those problem areas I do think it worked
well with all of my other products I
want to try this again once my skin
texture gets a little better because the
coverage is great but I'm not 100 sold
on this this is the kaleidos mono blush
in dreamwalk this kind of blue based
pink almost lilac color has been so
popular lately I was worried that it
would look weird on my skin tone but I
actually thought this was so pretty this
formula is so silky smooth it Blends out
beautifully and the pigment was on the
softer side but totally buildable and
easy to work with I like this color way
more than I thought I would these are
the kiss impress press-on falsies so
these are press-on lashes that don't
need glue and you apply them underneath
your lashes instead of above so it looks
more natural I'm not gonna lie I had a
really difficult time figuring these out
I don't wear falsies often so I'm
already not great at applying them but
this application process felt so much
harder because you apply them below the
lashes it made my eyes water which in
turn made the lashes not stick very well
I tried pressing them together with my
real lashes using the tweezers and my
fingers but they didn't feel secure at
all if I blinked too fast they would
just pop off these have a lot of great
reviews so they just might not be right
for me and my sensitive eyes I just
think applying falsies with blue feels a
lot more secure this is the REM Beauty
midnight Shadows lustrous liquid
eyeshadow in the shade fembot I've tried
out this formula before but this shade
in particular is having a moment on Tick
Tock it's this sheer pinky nude color
with a bunch of iridescent blue sparkles
in it it's really beautiful and Shifty
on the eyes I do think the best way to
apply it is with your fingers this
formula does dry down quickly but it
looks so cool and it doesn't settle in
the creases of my Lids elf just released
these o face satin lipsticks so I picked
up a couple Shades I'm just going to say
it these are incredible they are so
creamy and comfortable on the lips they
just glide on and the pigment is unreal
like these are one swipe lipsticks for
nine dollars they are a satin lipstick
so they do transfer but they are so good
I've been really excited to try this
Urban Decay quickie 24 hour multi-use
hydrating full coverage concealer it's
huge and it has a brush attached on top
this shade was a little too dark for me
but I tried to make it work I applied it
in all the areas I normally apply
concealer and I usually like to wait a
couple minutes before I blend it out but
this one dries down very fast I did have
a bit of trouble blending but I was
immediately impressed by the coverage
this gives I also think this brush is
actually good but I think the bristles
are too short I do think it's
interesting that it's described as a
hydrating concealer because to me it
leans more natural to matte but this is
a really good full coverage concealer we
have a new product from rare Beauty this
is the positive light under eye
brightener it has this metal applicator
that's supposed to be cooling for the
under eyes I blended this out with my
fingers and the coverage is definitely
sheer but I do think it brightened I
added a little more and it does build up
nicely while still feeling weightless I
applied my concealer on top and it
Blended out just fine I think this
formula layers really well and even
though the brightening is on the more
subtle side I can definitely see a
difference this is the Dior addict lip
maximizer Plumping gloss this gloss
looks so glittery and beautiful in every
single video I've ever seen of it but
unfortunately I didn't like it the
applicator is pretty small especially by
today's standards but that's not my
biggest issue with it it's the glitter
the glitter in this feels gritty on the
lips like when I rub my lips together I
can feel all that glitter and the
Plumping aspect was like non-existent I
saw and felt zero Plumping I wanted to
love it because it looks pretty but in
my opinion it's so not worth it let's
talk about the L'Oreal telescopic lift
mascara it has what they describe as a
double hook bristle brush which is
supposed to give you an instant lift and
volume I asked my editor Natalie to show
the full application process with no
Cuts so you can see how this mascara
actually performs I do really like how
it makes my lashes look but the brush is
not my favorite it picks up a ridiculous
amount of product look how much product
I scraped off the brush I felt like I
spent most of the time applying just
trying to remove excess products so it
wouldn't look clumpy I also got the
waterproof version and I found this
formula a lot easier to control I think
I prefer the waterproof version I
wouldn't say this mascara makes it look
like I'm wearing falsies but it
definitely gives me a lot of length and
lift and I will keep using it